Welcome
back everyone, toss a coin to your Witcher
they just dropped a whole bunch of footage
from the Witcher season 2 episode 1 and longer
trailer footage from later episodes.
So we'll break it all down there's a whole
bunch of Easter Eggs.
If you're brand-new to the channel, be sure
to subscribe to get all the episodes.
I will be doing videos for the Witcher season
2.
Just like I did for season one in they just
confirm that they renew the show for the Witcher
season three.
Although technically if you been watching
my videos.
We actually got news about that.
Like last year.
Like a long time ago.
They also announced the doing another anime
movie.
Like the nightmare of the wolf as you really
solid back story about Vesemir how he grew
up and became a Witcher the story of a giant
attack on Cam Ranh why got sacked and why
they can't create witchers anymore started
telling you that before season 2.
As you probably guess the reason why they
dropped that before season 2 is because were
going to Cam Ranh is ciri begins to train
as a Witcher and they learn more about her
power, but a lot of the footage here and I'll
just go through shot by shot talk about the
episode one scenes and the other trailer footage
most this is all from early on in season 2
episode one when they got to Nivellen's mansion.
So all this is from a grain of truth in the
books is a short story that takes place before
the events of blood of elves, which is what
they're using for most of the plot of season
2.
Because that's just the next book in the series,
so there's the next part of the story that
they're telling but because they skipped over
some of the early short stories they're just
jumping back and doing a grain of truth some
in the books the events of the story take
place way earlier in the timeline, and Ciri
was not there for what's going on but they
change that for the TV show.
If you're not familiar with a grain of truth.
I think I talked about this little bit in
my earlier videos is that is basically a darker
version of the beauty and the beast story
rehab the beast Nivellen who he's talking
to hear he's being played by Kristofer Hivju
who played tormund giantsbane during game
of thrones.
You might be able to detect his voice there,
but is kind of unrecognizable underneath those
prosthetics in the makeup the knives that
they're throwing at the picture there.
That's a picture of what he looked like before
he turned and the beast before he got cursed.
Just like beauty and the beast.
He did something terrible to get his curse
and in the Witcher universe.
Nivellen definitely deserves his curse he's
very remorseful about what he did.
It involves him in some of his former comrades
doing something really really terrible to
a young woman.
So he definitely earned the curse.
But the reason why the short story in the
episode is titled a grain of truth is because
this is whole idea of Geralt not fully understanding
what the dynamic is here with the beauty and
the beast scenario this playing out.
He kinda comes to the wrong conclusion initially
until he finds out what's really happening
in this first season 2 episode one clip you
to see him having a drink joking as if he's
been friends with the villain for a long time.
He does get a feel for his character.
He seems like a genuinely decent guy is not
quite like beast from beauty and the beast
in the second clip their still inside Nivellen's
mansion is just later in the evening and here's
this big screen in the background so he takes
his Witcher potions in his going out to fight
what he thinks is going to be a monster is
what is telling Ciri here.
Like stay here.
Don't do anything also because are kind of
afraid of series power as well.
Please trying to protect her, but also protect
her from her power.
If you want to make a marvel MCU comparison
she's kind of like a scarlet witch type of
character someone who's crazy OP but they
don't fully understand how her powers work
and she herself doesn't fully understand how
her powers were get so usually when she opens
up.
There's a lot of collateral damage.
But geralt is basically just yelling at her
like oh deal with this monster in the monster
you hearing in the background is actually
the beauty from this beauty and the b-storyline
the dark beauty and the b-storyline Nivellen's
lover vereena, who Carol thinks is secretly
feeding off of nivellen without his knowledge,
but then finds out that that's not the case
directly living in a really crazy codependent
relationship so that she do love each other
in this really sad dark ending to the episode
that we got our first look at Kim Bodnia is
a live action version of Vesemir a lot of
people just wondering what was going to look
like.
I think is a she could be pretty decent you
may remember him from killing eve Henry Cavill
said a lot of good things about his scenes
with him.
So I'm really looking forward to some Geralt
and Vesemir scenes with this is Vesemir meeting
Ciri for the first time.
If you play the video games you ask you saw
them after they been together and he been
training ciri for a long time after he become
old uncle Vesemir's working to watch that
slowly play out over the course of season
2.
It seems like Vesemir and the other witchers
are here when Geralt bring ciri in Cohen eskel
and Lambert are all kind of wary of Ciri once
Geralt explains what's going on with her once
they start to learn about her elder blood
powers, we see more of series, which are training
as a little bit of yennefer at the beginning
of season to remember she got captured by
the forces of Nilfgaard social be forced to
serve emperor emhyr for a little while.
But eventually she will be reunited with Geralt
and Ciri and even though there is in a bunch
of yes gear footage, he is going to be in
season 2 inches that in the book story that
they're doing for the first couple of episodes.
None of them are altogether it's really just
Geralt and Ciri, then yes gears off by himself
somewhere else in universe often Nilfgaard
also, by herself.
They have intercut this with a lot of footage
from season one.
So you a couple shots from season to if you
spotted any big Easter eggs or any big scenes
in the trailer that I didn't talk about in
the video just right them blown the comments
and I'll try to cover it in the comments.
I just try to do a quick reaction video here
because there's so much new footage Netflix
kind of did their big comic con event.
Today's that's why there's so many trailers
dropping I just did that new stranger thing
season 4 trailer video you can click here
for that and click here for my brand-new eternals
trailer video for kit harington's black knight
character that you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and toss a coin to your Witcher!